Die Dolomiten in Südtirol sind ein
Wintersportgebiet der Superlative.
Vom Grödnertal aus können Besucher
in wenigen Minuten
per Seilbahn die Pisten zwischen dem Berg
Langkofel und dem Sellamassiv erreichen –
auf mehr als dreitausend [zweitausend]
Metern Höhe.
Wir sind einer [eines] der schönsten
Skigebiete –
wenn nicht das schönste Skigebiet – weltweit,
verbunden mit sehr vielen Pisten.
Man kann nicht nur Ski laufen bei uns,
man kann langlaufen, man kann rodeln,
man kann eisklettern,
man kann wirklich alles,
was mit Winter zu tun hat,
kann man hier auf engem Raum machen.
Tausende Pistenkilometer in allen
Schwierigkeitsgraden
bietet Europas größte Skiregion
„Dolomiti Superski“,
ein Verbund von insgesamt zwölf
Skigebieten.
Touristen aus aller Welt haben hier Spaß
im Schnee.
Die Pisten sind alle miteinander verbunden
und die Abfahrten lang, das macht Spaß.
Gucken Sie die Kulisse an,
darum kommen wir gerne her.
Es ist toll und man isst gut!
Immer beliebter ist Eisklettern an den vielen
zugefrorenen Wasserfällen in der Region –
wie hier am 35 Meter hohen
Tervela-Wasserfall bei Sankt Christina
im Grödnertal.
Auf der anderen Seite wartet das
nächste Highlight:
Bergführer Hubert Moroder will mit zwei
Touristinnen den Eisfall Pilon besteigen.
Das Naturdenkmal ist 20 Meter hoch und sehr
beliebt in der Kletterszene.
Der erfahrene Eiskletterer und Bergführer
zeigt, worauf es ankommt.
Du schaust, den Fuß Richtung Mitte zu
stellen, bisschen höher steigen und dann
rechts,
wieder in der Mitte, ein bisschen nach links
und dann nach rechts,
[so]dass wir den Eispickel immer in der Mitte
vom Körper haben.
Bevor die Anfängerinnen loslegen,
klettert Hubert Moroder vor
und befestigt das Sicherungsseil
an speziellen Haken.
Am Anfang wird die Stelle so zweimal
gekratzt, bis ’s richtig beißt,
und dann kann man den ...
Daran können bis zu vier Personen
gesichert werden.
Das ist wichtig,
denn besonders bei den ersten Versuchen
verlieren Anfänger oft den Halt
und fallen ins Seil.
Lockeres Eis schlägt der Bergführer
zur Sicherheit weg.
Nach einer Viertelstunde müssen die beiden
Frauen erst einmal verschnaufen.
Man muss den richtigen Punkt suchen,
und ausprobieren, wo das Eis dich hält.
Anfangs hatte ich schon Angst, da ich Angst
hatte, dass das Eis bricht,
weil ich ja so was noch nie gemacht habe,
aber nein, es hält und es ist ziemlich hart.
Auch für geübte Bergsteiger ist Eisklettern
eine ganz neue Erfahrung.
Eispickel und Steigeisen muss man kräftig
ins spröde Eis schlagen.
Dabei wird einem trotz Eiseskälte
schnell warm.
Hubert Moroder führt regelmäßig
kleine Gruppen ins Eis,
überall in den Dolomiten.
Ich finde das ganz toll.
Man hinterlässt keine Spuren.
Es bildet sich immer ein bisschen anders,
es ist nie gleich schwierig wie das Jahr zuvor.
Und man kann immer andere Wasserfälle
entdecken,
die man vielleicht ... die letztes Jahr nicht
gefroren waren,
heuer sind sie wieder gefroren,
und ich finde das sehr toll.
Für die Pause zwischendurch gibt es
zahlreiche Berghütten.
Die sind im Winter nur per Seilbahn
oder Ski zu erreichen
und wetteifern mit kulinarischen Spezialitäten.
Manche Gäste kommen nur deswegen
hier hoch.
Die Sofie-Hütte auf der Seceda-Alm
in 2400 Metern Höhe
ist wegen ihrer Gourmet-Küche und ihres
italienischen Flairs besonders beliebt.
Hüttenwirt Markus Prinoth serviert traditionelle
Südtiroler Kost und eigene Kreationen.
Wir versuchen,
regionale Produkte zu verwenden,
zum Teil Bioprodukte.
Wir haben aber auch
eine mediterrane Küche,
eine internationale Küche,
wobei wir sehr [darauf] achten,
dass die Grundprodukte nicht zu sehr
manipuliert werden,
um den Eigengeschmack beizubehalten.
In den Dolomiten
warten noch viele Eisfälle darauf,
erklommen zu werden –
allerdings nur nach einem längeren Aufstieg.
Das Eisklettern boomt in Südtirol.
Ein Grund: Viele Wasserfälle sind
monatelang kletterfest.
Ein Schnupperkurs kostet etwa 125 Euro.
Die nötige Ausrüstung kann man ausleihen.
Ein halber Tag reicht, um das Klettern
am Eisfall auszuprobieren.